bazinga is not a scientific term but you
guys have had a lot of tongue-twisting
technical lingo throughout the run this
show
toughest thing you've ever had to say
well a lot of the science stuff is
really tough but I honestly it's more
than scientific or thoughtful concepts
that are really there I'm trying to
explain them that's where I get confused
because I understand it just enough to
mess myself okay real life
neuroscientists come on what would it
was tough for you anything Wow no
foreplay or anything just right to it oh
my um it turns out it can be tough
keeping it together we found plenty of
bloopers every once in a while before we
get into bed I put on a little show for
she can actually make a side effect like
10% chance of liver failure sound like a
90% chance of livers flop no idea oh
listen to me we can't do this I login
for how he's not complete nope
for how he's occupation shot what does
that happen
so who broke the must well Kaylie wins
that ground are you sure the guys are
cool with me going yeah of course why
this is usually something you guys do
together and if I'm those problems
no no no no no no no no there's a
million reasons of woman would shoot yes
moist palms dry mouth and localized
vascular throbbing
[Music]
[Applause]